you're not quite sure when you roll up
to a normal vacation rental
if it's actually the right vacation
rental right the lights are off you're
kind of like breaking in and so we
wanted to make that experience very
different at wander and what you'll
notice is the lights are on and you hear
this low thump of music playing it's
almost like there's this party happening
and you see the wander sign out front
and you very much know that this is
where you're supposed to be and then
when you get in you can unlock the door
obviously right through your phone turn
on and off the lights you see a little
handwritten note there from the team
basket of drinks and snacks Ghirardelli
chocolate at the bedside table all these
little touches that really say hey this
is all for you to enjoy you don't need
to worry about like stale ketchup in the
fridge or anything like that
all right guys bang bang I've got John
Andrew here with me uh I thought a great
place for us to start this conversation
would be the vacation rental market that
is not something that a lot of people
think about in the tech industry other
than when they're maybe going on
vacation you're building an entire
business here to go and kind of capture
this and improve that experience talk
about how big is that market why is this
so interesting to you and what exactly
do you think that you guys can do that
can improve it absolutely so the
vacation rental Mark has been around for
quite a while long before obviously
Airbnb and VRBO because renting other
people's houses particularly in Europe
was was very popular from a vacation
perspective now obviously there was a
whole bunch of problems when it came to
the discovery of certain locations and
that's where companies like the rbo and
Airbnb really started to flourish in
terms of thinking about the size of the
market Airbnb is now a 70-ish billion
dollar company with literally millions
of listings all across the world and so
in order to support a market cap that's
that large you can obviously imagine how
large the underlying actual inventory is
and so when we think about the space I
mean wander is today extremely extremely
small compared to like how big the
overall Market is but it's it's far
larger than I think most people realize
actually when you look at it as an
inventory perspective compared to let's
say say Marriott for example Airbnb is
many times larger in terms of total
number of rooms than even these massive
Hotel brands when you think about Airbnb
and VRBO what do you think they're doing
well and then where do you think the
areas that they either need to improve
or kind of the opening for you guys to
come in and actually have some sort of
disruption yeah so the thing that Airbnb
has done well I mean there's there's so
many things that they've done well
incredible team brand scale obviously
building a 70 billion dollar company is
no easy fee and the way that that team
navigated the pandemic and pre-ipo to
get to that point I found incredibly
impressive so I have nothing but
incredible things to say about about
that team but one of the consequences of
that type of scale is that you don't
really take into account the quality of
each and every listing on your platform
and that's obviously what leads to
sometimes a low customer satisfaction
related to certain States right you go
and rent this vacation rental and you
just doesn't look like the photos beds
are uncomfortable internet's bad and so
that's really where wander is trying to
play is this idea that when someone goes
on a vacation they want the quality and
consistency of a hotel but all the space
and privacy of their own vacation home
and so that's where we're trying to
enter the market but obviously building
that as a product because this really
relies on quite a bit of infrastructure
so when you talk about like the uh
privacy of their own home but all of the
things that you would get at a hotel I
think one time you told me like it's
like if Four Seasons had vacation
rentals right
um what does that mean right in terms of
like when I walk into one of these
wander homes what am I expecting what is
kind of the brand promise what are the
things that make it different than if I
just go rent you know Joe Blows uh kind
of location off of Airbnb yeah so the
first thing and I think this is
something that we've all experienced is
that you're not quite sure when you roll
up to a normal vacation rental
if it's actually the right vacation
rental right the lights are off you're
kind of like breaking in and so we
wanted to make that experience very
different at wander and what you'll
notice is the lights are on and you hear
this low thump of music playing it's
almost like there's this party happening
and you see the wander sign out front
and you very much know that this is
where you're supposed to be and then
when you get in you can unlock the door
obviously right through your phone turn
on off the lights you see a little
handwritten note there from the team
basket of drinks and snacks Ghirardelli
chocolate at the bedside table all these
little touches that really say hey this
is all for you to enjoy you don't need
to worry about like stale ketchup in the
fridge or anything like that and then
what we want to do as well is encourage
you to go and experience outside of the
property and so you can go right through
your phone unlock the Tesla in the
garage and go to one of the many curated
experiences that we have for you around
it so it's really trying to take what
people I think want which is a really
wonderful trip in a clean and consistent
home where they know that everything's
going to work and there's going to be
great customer support and you know have
a have a wonderful vacation but like I
mentioned before to deliver on that
requires a ton of infrastructure
Property Management building your own
booking platform building your own asset
management and so to a customer it's
just delivering on the brand promise but
the behind the scenes of all that is
pretty pretty wild so you mentioned
having a Tesla in the garage to then go
to curated experiences I don't think
many people would expect to get that
with their Airbnb rental talk a little
bit about uh providing a car picking
experiences like how do you do some of
the things outside of the actual home
experience itself yeah so in order for
us to provide that Tesla in the garage
it's not as simple as hey here's a car
as you would imagine we basically had to
build out effectively turo if you're
familiar with that product actually
within the wander app and experience so
you have to go right through the wander
app and upload your insurance and verify
your ID and we actually were able to get
direct apis access through Tesla so
shout out to the folks at Tesla for like
giving us API access so you can actually
like unlock the car right through the
wander app and that that whole dynamic
and so what you end up with is a lot of
very complicated systems for a very
simple user experience but to the
customer it sort of feels magical right
and that's really I think a big piece of
building a modern technology company and
product is abstracting away all these
complexities so that for the user it
just feels super super simple and where
are people going once they get in the
car are they going usually to like go
hang out with friends or are most people
using these curated experiences that you
guys have
yeah so we don't we don't obviously
track in terms of like where where
people go
um but we do we obviously see a lot of
it on social and otherwise and what you
see is basically this you know Tesla
with like the wander logo on the back in
let's say Redwood National Park or
outside of a great local restaurant and
that Dynamic is something that we really
love and encourage but it could be as
something as simple as like taking your
girlfriend in the car and just going on
a drive down the Oregon coast so I know
you keep calling this vacation rentals
but there's been this explosion of
remote work I know tons of people who
are like wandering around the world how
many of the people who are users and
consistently use the platform are
actually on vacation versus maybe they
are just remote working and kind of
hopping around various locations yeah I
I think that pretty much since the
pandemic and for a lot of people before
the pandemic the idea of work-life
balance and sort of drawing a Line in
the Sand started to disappear and it
sort of started to turn more into
work-life harmony right I think there
are very few people who can say when the
last time they went on a vacation was
where they never checked their email or
never had to do any work at all and so
what you end up with is this harmonious
relationship between who you are as a
person and your work and we find that
that's the case for most of our guests
as well and so supporting that with high
quality internet and great desk setups
and that Dynamic is super critical for
obviously satisfying that in the union
so what you end up with a lot of times
is someone who needs to hop on some team
call or a board meeting or whatever it
may be but then is able to take a deep
breath right after they turn off the
zoom and stare at the ocean or go
golfing or otherwise now how are you
finding the people to come and do this
is this all uh kind of just beautiful
pictures on The Internet Is It Word of
Mouth is it like some sort of viral
campaign what are you doing to actually
get people onto a platform because not
only are you competing with you know the
Four Seasons and various other hotels
you're competing with the airbnbs and
the vrbos like this is something where
they're getting bombarded over and over
and over again by these platforms saying
use us how are you guys break through
that noise
I think that really what it boils down
to is when we launched the company we
saw a really strong idea Market fit
everyone wanted to go to an incredible
location an incredible house and
understand that it was going to be clean
and connected and safe and so when we
were able to actually deliver on that
idea it instantly resonated with users
and it was something that they were
willing to try out I think a lot of
people who've stayed at a vacation
rental previously have always thought
wouldn't it be great if I had the
quality and consistency of a hotel in a
space like this and so that idea Market
fit and how it resonated with users led
to a lot of not just early adoption or
excitement around the idea but people
actually willing to to pay for it which
is a really critical Dynamic and then
from there what you really have is
Social proof so what a lot of people
look for is hey the people who have gone
and stayed at these properties did they
actually enjoy it what are they thinking
and the nice thing about wander is is
that so far we've been able to really
hold up our standards we have a 93.3
percent customer satisfaction rate which
is super high it's birthdays in America
is like 89 nine percent and so the vast
majority of people sort of sing our
Praises when they go and stay at a
property and that's resulted in a really
large portion of our overall revenue and
now what we're starting to see as the
platform matures is that repeat bookings
has become an even bigger part so I
think for March 30 of our bookings were
from repeat customers which is a pretty
wild Dynamic now this is not your first
company you've been starting companies
for a long time now you started when you
were very young talk a little bit as to
where does that entrepreneurial DNA come
from and what are some of the things
you've learned in those early things
that set you up to make this successful
yeah so I started my first company when
I was 13 14 and it's interesting because
when you sort of look back right as or
especially at the end of a long day
right at the end of a 14-hour day you
sort of have to wonder like what am I
doing with my life and why am I doing it
and so that question is something I've
reflected on quite a bit and thinking
back you know I was raised by a single
dad my pops up here he runs his own law
firm and I remember when I was super
young basically going to bed and waking
up at three four five in the morning
and walking downstairs and seeing him at
his computer working and all of a sudden
it clicked for me to sacrifice that he
was making picking up me and my sister
from school hanging out with us and then
working all through the night dropping
us off at school in the morning and then
going to work and doing it all over
again and so I think when I've reflected
on this question it really boiled down
to wanting to work like Dad which I
think for a lot of young men
um that tends to be a pretty strong
strong reason for me at this point now
my main motivation is is really making
people proud
um making the team proud making our
shareholders proud personal pride is
really my my motivation and what's nice
with that is that it's it's resulted in
a pretty endless stream of of energy and
always wanting to be better so very glad
that that's the motivation as opposed to
monetary or otherwise yeah that makes a
ton of sense now uh you also were a teal
fellow and talk all about that
experience and kind of was that
something that you're like I really
really want to get this was it something
that was kind of hey it'd be cool let's
see what it did like how did that work
yeah so for the listeners for context
that the teal Fellowship is a program
that was put together by Peter Thiel and
it was basically a grant based program
and network-based program for young
entrepreneurs who didn't go to college
and obviously Peter Thiel was one of the
early backers of Facebook and so I think
he saw a lot of this with Mark
Zuckerberg and and otherwise and so for
young people who are running a company
it's it's extremely lonely because your
peer group of other you know 17 year old
18 year olds are not exactly thinking
about the same things that you are and
of course who you're actually surrounded
with are people who are twice your age
and extremely experienced not just in
life but in their own fields and so what
you end up with is
massive incredible growth from an
entrepreneurial perspective at a very
young age but your social growth related
to people your own age is is relatively
limited and so it ends up being pretty
pretty lonely and so I think that he
identified this this sort of need of
course it's for a very small group of of
people right and so basically every year
there's a class of around 20
entrepreneurs
who become teal fellows they receive a
grant to a hundred thousand dollars
which for many of the entrepreneurs is
is incredibly key in terms of paying
their rent normally it's split across
their co-founders that Dynamic and it
gives them sort of a good jump start
along with a really great community
and so for me my my path into the teal
Fellowship was a little bit different uh
Peter Thiel and founderstone
participated in coders uh my second
company or first venture-backed
companies seed round and one of the
partners basically texted me and said
hey this is something that you should be
a part of
I ended up going through the interviews
and and participating in the program but
typically to your point uh there are
literally tens and tens of thousands of
applications and it's a super long
process but for me it was it was a
little bit different and when you think
about that experience you mentioned the
network and the people that you could
talk to is there one or two things that
you pulled out that you point back to
and you're like man I really learned
this there or I picked up this
experience that has helped me
yeah I can say that without the
fellowship I would have far fewer
friends in fact I would say that I
really wouldn't have any friends who
were sort of my age in building
companies and so that that effect has
has candidly changed changed my life to
to think that you know at this point now
I'm I'm 25.
um to think that I would have like no
friends is like would be a little bit
like sad in that in that context and so
that camaraderie and that that
Fellowship to uh to use the wording is
really really life-changing for a lot of
young entrepreneurs and when you think
about the companies that have come out
of the fellowship like figma for example
or uh ethereum like
those those Founders and I can say
likely that that benefit was felt by by
them as well and so it really does show
how
um how impactful the program has been
not just for these these young
entrepreneurs but also in terms of the
products that we use every day now you
mentioned coder and for those that don't
know I think you were like 16 17 years
old when you started this thing uh
Venture capitalists were not nice all
the time
um talk a little bit about uh what maybe
the best way to describe it's just like
VC on you because you're a 17
year old kid like what was the business
and what exactly was the VC uh treatment
of a young founder yeah so I started
coder at 17 18 with my co-founders Kyle
and Amar really incredible people
and as you would imagine a VC getting a
cold email from one of these teenagers
with no LinkedIn no experience or
otherwise uh isn't necessarily always
met with the best reaction let alone
when you have these teenagers who've
never pitched a VC and have no idea what
they're doing Beyond just creating a
really incredible product and standing
in front of you putting together you
know a demo or otherwise and so I have
tons of stories of VCS being
um blunt to sort of say the say the
least I remember once me and my
co-founder Amar we're in San Francisco
and we were going through a phase where
effectively we felt like we didn't want
to show our age and so we're the only 17
18 year olds in Silicon Valley who are
wearing button-ups and slacks which
obviously you know doesn't really fit in
sort of like uh IBM salesman is what we
is what we look like and so we go up
this massive Tower in the elevator and
we're standing in this office it's
overlooking the bay and we sit down and
we start to do this demo and basically
what happens is Amar had always used a
Linux laptop and Linux doesn't perform
very well on laptops and it constantly
drained the battery it constantly had
different issues and so we started to
demo the product
the laptop ended up running out of
battery and the the VC
um
basically at that point just started to
like chew us apart right it started to
like tear apart the business plan
started to tear apart the product you
know all these different pieces and I
remember ammar asked him uh what would
you do to fix it right because he was he
was really drilling into us and
he looked at us and he was clearly
prepared for and he said like that's why
you're here like you're you're supposed
to answer this question and so he ended
up sending us down the stairs with
basically this like vegan milk drink
that he had invested in uh which is such
like a classic like Silicon Valley event
um and we just thought that that he
hated it and then of course you know 20
minutes later we get an email that you
know he would love to participate in XYZ
we ended up not obviously having him
involved in the company
um but yeah it's really tough for an
early stage entrepreneur and you you get
very used to hearing no and my greatest
advice is to like just kind of laugh it
off and keep moving forward and you know
if you're persistent in building the
right idea then you should you should
build a successful company so yeah that
um that makes sense when you think about
at age 25 now running a business
compared to age 17 what are the things
that you did differently in setting up
wander that you didn't do before like
you know you had kind of couple shots on
goals so you learn the things to do and
maybe the things not to do are there any
major differences in the way you
structured the business how you hired
the team you know fundraising like what
are some of the things that you you kind
of implemented this time and you're like
yeah I actually learned that because I
was basically practicing in my uh
previous attempts yeah so you learn
quite a bit I would say the the big
things that you learn is really the
quality of your team and the quality of
your Executives is hyper important to
get correct in the early stages and so
for wander you know we we went from
starting the company to series a in
about 12 months so we we basically speed
ran the whole pre-seed seed
series a process and that boils down to
understanding and having extreme Clarity
in terms of what are the risks for the
business and what team do I need to hire
to de-risk those risks and figure out
related solutions to those problems and
so I'd say that was the biggest thing
for for wonder I had questions around
brand I had questions around technology
I had questions around the capital
markets and so I very quickly hired an
executive team that could solve those
issues now in the early stages an
executive team doesn't necessarily mean
people who just sort of like point and
say hey do this and goes and builds out
a 20 person team you need people who can
actually get their hands dirty but are
experts in their field and then of
course you don't want to miss a beat
when you go and raise your 20 million
dollar series a or whatever it may be
and so they also have to be able to go
and and manage that team as well so that
was probably the biggest thing is
understanding what are the risks in this
business and how can I hire the right
Executives who are able to effectively
solve those problems and improve a
thesis that if we do we'll allow the
business to get to the next stage how
about managing a team as a young person
right if you're hiring a bunch of people
who are in their 30s and you're 17 or 25
uh there's some weird Dynamics
um people have heard me talk on the
podcast before I went to uh the military
I got deployed overseas I was 20 21
years old
um and I was there with a bunch of older
guys and you know one you're learning a
lot and kind of like oh you know
mortgages and families and uh kids like
all this stuff at the same time uh
there's times where you're in charge and
like you gotta kind of convince someone
who is looking at you like what the hell
do you know to actually you know be a
participant of the team and execute uh
in this great way what are some of the
things you've learned there to be
effective yeah as a young person what
you have to realize is that you're all
compute in no context you can sort of
think about it like a new computer where
the CPU and everything works very well
but your hard drive is completely empty
and so you have to be extremely
attentive and thoughtful to the people
who are around you and listen and really
try to deeply understand what their
concerns are what they're going through
your point around mortgages and kids and
that Dynamic is something that a young
person simply doesn't understand but
it's a really big and important piece of
the lives of the people who report to
you right they're worried about making
their mortgage payments they have kids
that are sick all these different ideas
and so as a young leader you have to
learn and understand those pressures and
who they are as a person and it sort of
forces you to think far beyond your
years even though it's not personally
something that you're going through you
end up having to feel this really deep
compassion and empathy for people's life
circumstances and what that ends up
creating is I think a decent amount or
it sort of forces you to have a decent
amount of social intelligence related to
managing people who are far above your
age and also what it does is it it
forces you to try and learn as much from
them as humanly possible so the way that
I always looked at it was okay I have
you know all this compute but an empty
hard drive and this person has an
incredibly full hard drive full of life
experiences and otherwise I'm going to
try and like copy paste as much of that
data as possible and see what I can
learn from this individual but it's
certainly hard and it's certainly a
process and a lot of the things are
going to seem foreign and the best
advice that I can give to all the young
people and young managers out there is
to really be thoughtful to really listen
to understand that you're dealing with
other people's lives
and to leverage their experience and at
the end of the day yes you have to be
the one to make the decision and you
should trust trust your instinct in that
in that regard but you need to make sure
to also treat people with respect and
compassion and do realize that even
though you're you're in charge you
ultimately have far less experience than
they do and so you should show them
incredible respect yeah that makes a uh
that makes a ton of sense uh I believe
that you were a formula driver early in
your teenage years
um were you any good one and two is
there something that like is there some
correlation between the same type of
person who would get in the car and try
to go fast as the same person who you
know early in their life wants to start
a bunch of companies like what are some
of the lessons that we can take from
that yeah so I I did used to race
formula cars so I started out in Formula
Mazda and this is the effect too of what
happens when you have a kid who's doing
High School online and has some level of
disposable income because they're going
to travel around the world and be like
hey I'm gonna race cars why not
um so I raced formula cars out in in
Texas formula Mazda I ended up doing
pretty well I finished second in
Nationals uh and then I ended up
graduating into F4
um and yeah I mean it's highly
competitive and very data focused for me
I think I always knew that I wasn't
going to become a professional race car
driver and of course all the kids around
me this was going to be their career
this was their life path and journey so
I really got to enjoy it uh enjoy the
speed and the danger and all that sort
of fun stuff it did ended up catching
catching up to me I ended up breaking my
back twice sort of on on two two
different occasions
um which it like always makes things a
little bit harder so now I like to joke
that unlike the body of a 90 year old
pen like a little bit a little bit
creepy in that respect but I certainly
have a lot of pretty epic memories so
yeah I would say so it's very
competitive and a team sport as well and
the adrenaline and the speed and high
risk I think uh there's a lot of
parallels with entrepreneurship I want
to do a little bit of around on Robin of
a bunch of topics that people seem to be
very interested in right now you're a
young person who's in the technology
sector for a while you know tons of
different people you have a lot of these
conversations you've got very smart
people that work for you and so I
thought maybe the first place to start
would be with the current banking crisis
we've seen tons and tons of uh Banks who
have come under pressure some of them
have failed some of them have liquidated
themselves uh and I think there's still
a lot of uncertainty about what will
happen moving forward we've also seen
this massive response from the
government whether it's you know
Discount Windows lending programs uh you
know nationalization just in some
degrees and receivership all this
different stuff uh you guys at the end
of the day do have real estate right it
is a part of your business how are you
all affected by that what are you seeing
from some of the lenders that you work
with what kind of can we take away from
your experience so far with this banking
crisis absolutely so for for The
Listener a really good way to think
about it is is that with the FED having
raised interest rates so dramatically
effectively it's created a credit crunch
within a lot of these local and Regional
Banks who were the primary lenders for a
lot of commercial real estate and so
what's ended up happening is is that
with the collapse of certain Banks like
svb and now First Republic you're
sorting you're starting to see a lot of
other local Regional Banks sort of
tighten up on their Lending so that
result means that there's not going to
be a lot of new commercial real estate
projects necessarily so think like new
construction buildings and then also of
course what you end up having is a lot
of a lot of commercial real estate is
going to come up for refinancing as well
over the next 12 to 24 months and so
that that is going to lead to some
really interesting circumstances when
you pair that with extremely low vacancy
particularly in markets like San
Francisco and Chicago and so I'm not I'm
not actually sure what the government is
going to do or what these Banks and
investors are going to do when this
happens I think a lot of investors are
going to end up being being wiped out
and take pretty significant losses but
it may reach the point where the fed and
the government generally may need to
step in and do some do some some easing
in that regard but this Dynamic which is
really fascinating is that effectively
this credit crunch that's happening with
these these Regional Banks is having the
same effect as the FED increasing their
rates and so that's something that
they've talked about more broadly is
this idea idea that rate hikes may
actually slow down or be paused simply
because Banks today are in lending which
obviously slows down the economy which
satisfies the goals of the FED as it is
today
related to wander we're obviously not in
traditional commercial real estate so
we're obviously in short-term rentals in
the vacation rental and travel space and
so we've benefited from The Continuous
you know Tailwinds of the short-term
rental and travel space very very
fortunately but for a lot of other
different types of commercial real
estate like uh office or even some
industrial for example they're certainly
starting to suffer and having trouble
meeting their yields and
um it's it's a real issue for for the
country and hopefully I think
um there's some type of action taken
before the results of that are felt as
opposed to what's happening currently
which is we're sort of waiting for banks
to fail we're waiting for uh you know
buildings to go into foreclosure Etc
before we do anything and it would be
nice to be a little bit proactive about
that or at least that's that's what I'd
love to see the country do but we'll
sort of see what happens
so another topic that people are very
interested in is artificial intelligence
although you all have the real estate
you also are a technology company and
there's a lot of things that you're
doing that uh maybe we can call Auto
Magic right where uh people walk up and
they can unlock a door that's not their
door with their phone or maybe get into
a Tesla like all these different things
um so that's some degree of automation
or kind of this Auto Magic what else are
you all uh doing internally and then
what are you excited about coming out of
that sector yeah so the a really great
way to think about the shift that
artificial intelligence is going to have
is that it's going to create incredible
operational efficiency on companies that
typically had to have a very head count
heavy operational structure right so
customer service is going to end up
being automated away anything that
anyone does really just behind a
computer will end up being automated
Away by these various AI agents and so
what you have is the efficiency unlocked
and typically very operationally complex
businesses that would have historically
low margins due to the number of W-2
employees and so for wander one thing
that we're working on you know pretty
pretty intensely is the augmentation of
our concierge service so that when
someone reaches out to us and they say
hey we'd love to go and book this
restaurant can rather than a human do
that can we use an AI agent and related
automations to be able to go and
effectively do that without a person
intervening and so that's just on the
customer support side but then you look
at the property management side and the
automation of certain contractors and
cleaning crews and otherwise and what
you end up with is basically a system
that theoretically could scale to
hundreds or thousands of properties with
a very very low head count and it sort
of sounds outrageous today but it's
certainly where the world is moving I
think today IBM announced that
effectively they're not hiring any more
W-2 employees where the jobs could be
done by Ai and that is fully the world
that we're moving towards is that
companies with fewer people are going to
be able to do the jobs and tasks of
companies with thousands of people and
that's going to lead to incredible
operational efficiency and
basically business models that didn't
work before the technology will now
start to work and so if you're in one of
those operationally intense businesses
definitely leveraging Ai and making sure
that as a founder and entrepreneur you
understand how it works in the systems
and have a vision for it is hyper
critical because if not you'll be sort
of left in the dust yeah I think that's
a great way to look at it um are you
seeing anything change internally with
the use of this stuff in terms of uh
tools that people are using or various
types of products that you can build now
that maybe you couldn't build previously
yeah absolutely I mean I think it's
something like
70 and and this this should be fat
checked but 70 of Engineers are now
leveraging ai tooling and it's it's a
pretty remarkable shift in terms of AI
code completion and a company I'm a big
fan of sourcegraph just released
basically a context aware code search
where you can effectively ask it queries
and
um it'll give you answers related to
that code base and so that augmentation
is happening very quickly and that
results in a lot of training as well and
that training is going to result in
these these
um the sort of like AI code companion
um becoming a bigger and bigger piece of
an engineer's life until ultimately
large swaths of software are going to be
effectively automated which will be a
really incredible
um effect like imagine if rather than
building a website and it taking let's
call it a week anyone anywhere in the
world could ask let's call it like chat
GPT or whatever to say hey make me this
website and it took a day and costs
nothing
and so basically like the idea that
software could be free-flowing for
everyone is going to yeah it's gonna
It's Gonna Change Change the World and
it's coming for everyone as well like
you know copywriting and uh graphic
design and accounting I mean the really
no very few people are safe from uh from
a job perspective even me as a CEO you
think about this like AI uh that has all
the context in the world to make
decisions you know really all I am at
that point is just a smiling face and so
it's going to be really interesting to
see what happens over the next few years
and and how the right leaders you know
integrate it into their business and the
thoughtful and human way
another area that people are very
excited about is Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies what are you seeing
there or what do you think is exciting
yeah so obviously what's happening in
the banking industry is not necessarily
great for
um creating Assurance or confidence in
the US dollar uh especially too when you
think about some of the the moves that
that China and Russia are making even
China and Saudi Arabia in terms of doing
dealings in the one
and so what you end up with is basically
looking at why or what did Bitcoin and
crypto come out of and of course it came
out of the 2008 crisis when people
weren't exactly confident in the banking
infrastructure and so I think that what
you're going to see is is that
previously the sort of flood into crypto
was driven by low interest rates and
speculation but now you're starting to
see confidence in it from an actual like
utility perspective and so it's going to
be really interesting to see that shift
again especially if we see continued
bank failures how more and more
countries and more and more individuals
are going to start to leverage it you're
also seeing pretty rampant inflation in
places like Argentina and otherwise and
so those types of people and the people
in those countries really have no choice
but to move to some other currency
whether it's the US dollar and of course
if you don't have faith in the US dollar
then what what currency are you moving
into and crypto certainly has a
potentially big place in that future but
I think that as that happens you're
seeing more and more regulation around
it right because obviously threatening
the US dollar is going to result in
quite a few folks in power sort of
looking at these different
cryptocurrencies like you see what's
happening right now with coinbase and
the wells notice and otherwise
and so it's going to be really
interesting to see what happens from
that perspective is that even if you
have this decentralized currency if all
the governments say that it's not
allowed then you know it's going to end
up being a sort of Black Market item so
it's I candidly don't know what the
future is going to hold for it um but
what I can say is is that we're
certainly seeing the reason it exists
um all around us yeah I think that's
right
um you all are interesting because you
have software and then you have clinical
Hardware which is really kind of real
estate in physical spaces there's been a
very big rise in whether you want to
call it American dynamism whether you
want to call it space exploration uh
manufacturing like there's all these
kind of things in and around uh the
combination of software and Hardware
that are now coming together and
becoming quite popular what are you
seeing there maybe places that you take
inspiration from but also places that
you're paying attention to that are
outside of what you all are doing I
think as you see this shift where
software is becoming sort of easier and
easier to create that more and more
businesses and servicing new ideas are
going to have some type of Hardware
component to them and that that result
is going to be especially if it's in an
idea space that consumers feel strongly
about
are going to build some pretty important
companies Tesla being a great example
obviously an incredible software company
but has built an incredible cult brand
around the physical Hardware as well
Apple being another example this idea of
having this physical object with
software great software as well and that
creates really high moat and durable
companies because no matter what anyone
else does they're not going to have
Apple's hardware and in wander's case no
matter what anyone else does they're not
going to have our homes and so that
Dynamic I think is is going to continue
for new companies tackling Big Ideas now
they are going to be a little bit slower
to scale again Tesla's a 20-something
year old company Apple's a 40 something
year old company but the result should
be a much more durable durable business
and so I think that more VCS as again
you see the like abundance of software
are actually going to start turning to
some of these higher mode type
businesses yeah when you see that moat
developing to me I always come back to
this idea of
um you have the hardware you have the
software but also there's this I'm going
to call it like cultural thing going on
as well where you know take the Android
of the world take these spacex's like
these very big companies that are
matching hardware and software but it
almost feels like they're able to
recruit because they literally just say
this is important right and
um I know that there's been a a rise of
all kinds of different tools and this
and and you know single person companies
like some of the things we even talked
about today how important is it to be
able to recruit people recruit investors
and ultimately recruit customers by
somebody just putting the flag on the
ground saying hey this is important
yeah
when the way that I like to think about
it is that let's like flash back to like
ancient Sparta right when Warriors would
go to war they weren't doing it because
of their compensation packages they were
doing it because they were going to war
with a leader and an ideology and a
mission that they believed in and when
you think about building a great culture
and a great company people aren't going
to give it their heart and soul unless
that Dynamic is also true now of course
I'm not equating working at a tech
company to being a you know Spartan
warrior but the idea that people need to
be passionate and believe in something
and believe in their leadership is still
extremely relevant and so that's why a
lot of great companies are able to
recruit really incredible Talent even
though the compensation packages may be
less or otherwise is because they truly
believe in in the mission statement and
it's something that they want to
dedicate their life to and have a real
purpose and so as long as humans aren't
robots and simply make decisions and a
like extremely logical framework and
actually you know have ideologies and
beliefs then that Dynamic is going to
continue and it's something that's super
important and candidly I think it's it's
a very very good thing for for Humanity
yeah uh when you start looking for
talent what are some of the things that
you're looking for and where are you
finding uh kind of people today and I
would love for you to tell me your
secrets as to where you're finding these
people but kind of what does that
process look like uh obviously you guys
have all these locations right into kind
of I'm assuming most of the team is
remote and it opens up opportunities but
also makes things more challenging talk
through that a little bit yeah so as as
someone who grew up as an internet kid I
sort of have this deep intuition when it
comes to undiscovered young Talent right
I can see from you know someone's GitHub
it's like the 17 year old 18 year old
kid with you know thousands of commits
and like working on these like great
open source projects and of course they
would flunk a uh an interview with
Google and also a recruiter on LinkedIn
isn't going to necessarily find them if
they have they probably don't have a
LinkedIn at all and so finding those
types of people and bringing them into a
culture where you don't need to have 20
years of experience and understand the
politics of a workplace like we value
output and camaraderie and like building
then they tend to be extremely high
output and it ends up putting their
career on a vastly different and more
productive track and so that's really
what I focus on across all the different
aspects of the business no that's very
different than when you look at your
leadership team when you look at your
leadership team you're paying for
someone who's been there and done that
and has some type of x expertise in the
field but they need to be able to manage
those types of very high output
individual contributors that are on a
ray upward trajectory in their career
and so that's that's really what I focus
on and then over top of that just their
raw abilities is I really focus on
compatibility so does this person have
shared ethics are they a good person
would they stop and help someone change
a flat tire and so that's that's
something that we really focus on as
well and what that results in is a
really high output culture with very few
um what's what's the best way to put it
uh very few negative people so to speak
as you continue to build uh this
business what are the biggest risks what
are the things that you kind of keep you
awake at night and you're like hey we
got to mitigate this or get rid of this
yeah so the biggest risk for wander at
this point is is scale so when we when
we first launched we had a bunch of uh
questions right could we build this
booking platform or the customer uh
experience be better you know would we
be able to build the asset management
all these different pieces are the unit
economics positive tons of tons of
questions
for the most part all those questions
have now been answered and customers
truly love the product and so we sort of
satisfied that like why combinator
philosophy of build something that
people love but now the question is how
do we scale that across the us across
the globe and that's a really
complicated Dynamic and something that
if startups are so lucky you're going to
face at some point right once you build
something that people love then if
successful you're going to have to scale
it and so that's really the phase that
wander's going through right now and I
hope that I can look back on this
podcast in five ten years and be like
wow like you know we figured that out
like holy crap
um but yeah it's certainly a tough a
very tough Dynamic that I think a lot of
companies go through and I just I feel
very lucky to to be faced with that
challenge but that is really what keeps
me up at night at this point is you know
really capturing the full potential of
this company and figuring out how do we
scale to you know thousands of locations
I think that is a great place to end
this conversation because uh
understanding risk but also saying hey
when I get there and I look back here's
what I want to believe I think is a
great way to not only minimize risk but
also it's a great way to really
understand what are you building right
it's kind of like if you start at the
end and then work backwards uh it helps
you really understand what that North
Star is we're going to send people to
find you on the internet or find out
more about wander absolutely so the
company's website is wonder.com and it's
at wander on all the different social
media platforms and then for me
personally my name is John Andrew
untwistle so on Twitter and all that fun
stuff and thank you all so much for
listening and thank you for for taking
the time to talk to me I really
appreciate it I learned every time we
talk so I appreciate you taking the time
to do this and uh although you have been
at this for a long time you still got a
long uh kind of portion of your career
ahead of you so I'm excited to see what
else you do once you build this business
into an absolute Giant and I appreciate
you taking the time to come on here
we'll definitely do it again in the
future amazing thank you so much